is the most wonderful time of the year
again the twelve thousand and nineteen
human era calendar is out he'll get our
new limited edition now or regret it
forever we heard your comments on last
year's edition so we've updated the
design each illustration is now featured
on a full page with so much more space
to take notes below exactly two point
three six six eight nine times as much
as in the old layout also the calendar
has a spiral binding shiny silver
letters on the cover and is printed on
high quality paper that's nice to touch
the calendar looks awesome on your wall
but it's also the easiest way to tick
off your whole present list for
Christmas if you order now it would
arrive before the holidays and it's the
perfect gift for your friends kids
grandma dog Oh mortal enemies or random
strangers you meet on the street on the
inside you find 12 brand-new beautiful
illustrations of early human cultures
and craftsmanship prior to the first
civilizations in the use of metal this
topic is endlessly fascinating to us our
ancestors achievements from 10,000 years
ago paved the way for our modern
civilization so we can only dream of
what might be possible in the future
through human cooperation by the way if
you're wondering about the date we
explained white 1019 should be our
current year in our a new calendar for
Humanity video order your calendar now
it will be available as a limited
edition until our stock is sold out and
then never again the human calendar is a
Superfund site project we got to do for
the third time thanks to your support we
loved getting mails tweets and pictures
with your calendars from over 80
countries last year so we're already
looking forward to all your messages
right
[Music]